the crew though a bunch of us were
playing it last night including yourself
peter hommerson good plated that's true
we played the Alpha about a month ago
which was good fun we drove from Detroit
to san francisco and i think it took
about an hour and 20 minutes is a long
time yeah you want to get out of Detroit
pretty much as best as you can't
regardless it's the first thing i did
yesterday was go to New York Lydia was
going a wonderful road trip cuz as far
as European me is concerned this is
actually a pretty accurate
representation well over the United
States and like you know I grew up
obviously on games and stuff and I've
played you know my fair share of racing
games from you know you know Gran
Turismo to you know even need for speeds
like that but when I found out that the
the conceit of this game was that you
could literally drive from you know New
York to LA which one is it blew my mind
she's from an open world multiplayer
standpoint it's like that's pretty
incredible so this'll actually the first
time that I get a chance to see it so
Axl I saw the stuff from the beta but
this is the first time I've actually
seen it work what did I show you and
you're voicing then at that stage we had
some pretty cool they did the mocap
separate from the vo which is kind of
against the trend now but they had been
fairly good the first time I saw their
facial capture I was pretty pretty
impressed by it um I play Alex Taylor
like who says the co2 [ __ ] dist yes
easy a very good gordon freeman
cosplayer it is the most Glinda what's
so funny is travis willingham as my best
friend plays my brother in this which
we've done a few times at this point and
i was like if i look this old and I'm
the younger brother how old is drive in
Travis looks 50 yeah um but you know how
you're a 5-10 so that's the whole thing
about this is what is it Chuck do don't
worry about that's right cuz i got thank
you what do you do this is what you're
doing yeah there you go that's just like
out [ __ ] he's looking let's check out
the dump truck want a tire iron man send
your part send your part to HQ press X I
got it so in the crew you were basically
infiltrating this 510 well so what
happens is you play as alex taylor and
in the very beginning of some pot boiler
but as like prologues you know start off
um you witness your brother get shot and
killed in front of you you get framed
for it
you go to jail but the FBI decide that
they are going to use you to try to take
down the rival gang to your brother's
gang which were the five tens so I'm a
star FBI dude exactly you know I'm a
gritty gritty actually it's very hot FBI
chick yes she's a very attractive woman
so it's kind of bucking the trend there
um but yeah so you play you play as alex
taylor and you you as a player and also
you as Alex are trying to rank up within
the five tends to kind of take over
where your brother left off and usurp
the rival gang but you have your own
motives yeah you want to murder the [ __ ]
out of that one dude and super pissed
yeah go with that that's that was kind
of like paraphrased plot points one of
the things I loved about this was that
when I jumped in you could just drive
anywhere so like I get the silly stuff
yeah there's all those checkpoints all
everybody's it's your typical ubisoft
fanfare of here are all of the things
you need to do but they didn't like gays
it in any way so I just drove straight
to New York hit Times Square on the
google maps thing they just tear around
the industrial district I've Detroit
roight no I heard I asked someone what
type of a gun in New York and they said
it well I drove through it once i was
like troll how do you drive through
manhattan on the way to London that's
the worst driving directions ever go
through one of the most congested cities
in this yeah sure we'll just stop
through uh you know it'll take three
hours to go to two blocks but not in the
crew because it's not the same size of
New York thankfully it's a smaller
version is that you of engine cars yeah
there's some missions where you get to
take on a different car just for that
mission alone these new driver san
francisco just teleport into that one no
I got out of my car Guzman do you know I
did not really the the player-character
below the waist there are no legs that's
what do you don't know about there are
no legs and that is the miracle of this
game
be this good of a driver but no legs
yeah how do you you know get yourself
into the mind space of someone with no
legs when your voice to him well you
know I take the shia labeouf approach
and I just cut my legs off yeah method
just get into sending it and then get a
rest here at Peter and then claim that I
was raped oh yeah whatever Wow follow
the full playbook yeah crazy I just got
home the Shia LaBeouf me last week I was
like yeah i was i was actually pulling
off hope I'm so glad that we're on topic
right now um I was pulling out hope for
him and then and then all this just the
one hour silent interview i wouldnt hear
about that one he did he agreed to do an
interview with someone and he said we're
not going to speak we're going to be
silent and i'm going to strap a camera
to my head and a camber to your head and
they sat in silence for an hour and that
was the interview is probably the most
intelligent interview whatever he's ever
given that i wanna show you what we're
doing for the shadow of mordor demo
that's i want to play that shia labeouf
interview on the oculus rift yeah it's
so real i feel like i'm actually there
oh no I'm so much they want to throw I'm
sorry Shia LaBeouf and son I'm just he's
Gibby so dreaming he loads the fodder
cannon himself yeah so can't help it
fire it at peter brian whatever the
obviously already started reviewing this
game last night we're gonna get a review
on a slightly later on this week or
early next week but what are your
impressions so far are playing this
bubble how long have you played for a
while what are you taking away from it's
about four hours guys not so much done
not that much you know it's it's kinda
like an arcade eraser you have the
option to like turn off some of the auto
assist stuff to make it a little bit
more sunlight but really it's pretty
forgiving for the most part so you kind
of have fun in tool around you know like
they're a lot of missions to do their
fun there's good about a variety can you
feel the difference between the cars a
little bit okay a little bit at the
start you kind of you don't get that
much are you still on the street starter
kit because they kind of give you that
well you're on stock you know which
comes with nitrous like all stock cars
no of course yeah okay uh let's go yeah
that stuff just comes in a straight-up
dealership yeah it is I'm not being
stupid but I'm serious like so what are
some of the features like with the the
DualShock for anything nothing that I'm
aware of that special you click it
comes on yeah yeah that's the feel eat
at totally gotta get first place here um
the one problem i have with the game is
that it's required to always be online
even when you're doing missions solo and
you know okay it's a pain in the ass
right but then like you know this game
supposed to have missions that last for
a considerable amount of time like an
hour two hours you want dial-up they can
take charge for the second well the
problem you know is that like if I'm
playing an experienced a little blip
like you know let's say there's some lag
like someone in your house is like said
it looks downloading to the other and
the phone line sure okay yeah anyway
long story short long mission last name
their way about games mom a mission last
thing on my roommate we're on the same
network and he experiences like a little
bit of a connection thing like at the
very end of a mission yeah he gets
kicked off gets no rewards / having done
that so if I'm playing a mission that's
like two hours long what happens to me I
am I sure could I'm very much ready to
just put down a controller and flip out
I could end up a more of an issue with
sort of the saving like isn't that
something do you think that's something
they could that could be addressed by
oleg like a patch quick saving stuff or
like sure but that's not reality yeah
not what the reality is you're currently
yeah it's tough with these because like
it feels kind of like criticizing like
world of warcraft for being always
online sounds a little absurd it's like
we're in beta testing this game for
months now like I can't imagine that
hasn't come up and they haven't thought
about oh well how do we rectify this I'm
looking forward to doing a two hour one
or one of the long ones over the wheel
yeah totally so hopefully that will come
up is that I mean does that just involve
like driving the eastern seaboard or is
there are there like multiple stages to
missions like do the first disperse race
and then that's gonna combo to this race
in another car and it's like kind of a
rally kind of like yeah like different
different cars changing across the road
all their user agreement Gordon Freeman
huggin I I got a question here from
darkbeat on twitch he's asking how
diverse are the locales in the game
everything kind of looks so far at the
same I can attest to this from playing
the i think it was it out for the beta
we went to Salt Lake City because Andy
Berman video producer as from Park City
and it obviously looked totally
different with like snowy Tundra whatnot
but one of the things he pointed out was
even though the cities themselves
weren't
like you know one-to-one or anything
they couldn't be he said it was the best
model of the tabernacle he'd ever seen
yeah he's seen a lot more little B
please don't worry about that and like
San Francisco and you're coming over the
Bay Bridge like the the sign has faced
the wrong way because it wouldnt
couldn't see if there was in the game I
guess but like it looks really faithful
like it looks look it reminded me out
driving across the bay bridge and then
when he got there he like I wasn't one
to one but they might you know is it a
game where you trying to make Google
Maps yeah we strive to Chicago or
something get get out get a drug show I
can fast travel there we drive across
the little uh i mean i don't know how
are you allowed to go there is it what
you can't yeah you gotta go there you
can write fast travel once you've been
to that's right and all this stuff yet
this is like new only did get away
London you know and that was like I mean
I had a friend of those holy shits my
flat you know like you could actually
drive past and it was like a google map
saying but that's London which is a
fairly condensed city or like in second
son what we did Seattle it's you know
it's it's you could you could somewhat
do that one to one I don't even see how
it would be possible to design for that
and I don't know if I would have wanted
them to focus on that ISM at the yeah BS
tour the deficit of systemic stuff yeah
I don't actually want to dry like it
would take seven hours to drive to LA
from semitech oh and that's just getting
no no no think seven hours about getting
another four or five it again seven
temperature yeah that's a good bamberg
yeah yeah you definitely wouldn't want
you appreciate the sort of mushing
around of geography that a game like
this does and that they have to strike
that balance of you know making the
spacious spaces feel that way without
then like capturing the actual horrible
grind of driving across Nebraska
straight for four hours where you shoot
yourself in the head halfway through oh
my god it's really a gas to get it I
just spent a week in Kansas did you did
you go out and drive on some highway
road like oh I didn't drive i was was
draped yeah today and I did yeah it was
looking for you say me I got the cereal
America your where you view from Texas
from Texas are really a party is used to
doing a lot of Dallas oh I live there to
see I mean dude it takes six hours just
to get out of state I'm not kidding it's
terrible where were you you were in
dallas yeah i was near mockingbird
station oh that you
there's no there's not another turn up
there man that's what I say don't think
that my calculated this all kinds how
it's done and reckless disregard for
your own car is how we do in the croup
well that's a question how physics wise
how is like damage that you take is I
just realize your windshields back to
normal you take damage and like I so
last night I took a bunch and I didn't
really feel like any sort of hindrance
on my on the driving mmm maybe there is
doesn't cost you either I don't think
cuz you wreck your car Burnett style if
you like go fish so totally yeah then it
puts you back like with some damage I
think they'll be frustrating though for
predominantly racing game like in GTA it
works because you just get out steal
another car Yeah right but I think it
would be incredibly frustrating if you
know one of the AI trafficked or
whatever yeah decided to make a right
term yeah no I mean I think the arcade
sort of you know like qualities of this
game where it's really forgiving it's
not really a simulator that's cool
that's fine like I'm totally okay with
that there's what it is has anybody come
out with like third-party like wheels
yet anything I mean I always liked the
next-gen stuff yeah I don't haven't seen
it cuz I keep my eye open for the
formula yeah I think thrust at Gators
got a new version out I'm not sure
actually if its co-op if it's compatible
with next-gen systems but I wasn't
anything I was no high-end one yet so
who's racing gauges that had a drive
club but yeah I'm that dollars on the
arcades I just did where a lot for
terrorizing is kind of yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't call driveclub necessarily like
what a game I want to play with a with a
wheel and which was weird because it
looked like it was gonna fill that gap
for at GT when it was coming on yeah but
sadly not and what am I mission variety
so far have you like yeah those races
and like we had point stuff yeah I do
like they're these missions where you
have to sort of like chase people like
you know a takedown style like damage
their car and put out of commission and
you get to ride these like raid vehicles
they're like you know kitted out with
like four wheel drive and you know
really durable components um and those
are fun but they're also really hard and
the one thing about them that strained
is like the AI is really really fast and
smart I guess he actually know what my
name in akola day I they seem to be on a
fixed path and so the problem is that
you're trying to chase someone who's
really really
quick and then they make these turns at
a fixed point at least it seems don't
lock our style slot cars like they just
do a 90 degree 90 degrees sure yeah okay
yeah but so you wouldn't there's no way
for you to know that that's happening
and that's your best chance to take them
down so if you miss that opportunity you
have to do it again but in what you see
is the next time they do it the same way
so it's kind of like this setup where
it's like you're meant they're all rails
yeah and like yours I mean it seems that
way yeah and so you have to sort of
trial and error your way to victory i
meanin which is I think kind of shitty
because you should be able to succeed on
your own merits as a driver right but
you you like there's nothing you can do
with your own skill to decipher when
they are going to do what they're going
to do how far is gonna be the best you
can be be all you can be damn what
you're seeing now in this zone is ya the
truth of all American cross country
driving rise when you come close to a
big city first you must pass through its
industrial wasteland sir that is one to
one so is that what Oakland is then for
some Francis that is that is what
Oakland affordable cone is seriously now
here's a question for you because Steve
jaros who who used to be at volition
Isaac valve um said one thing that's
really hard about a open-world game is
you can't put a ticking clock on it
which invariably for a racing game
that's what you have you ever racing but
but it's right like completing missions
and stuff like that it's really hard
when you say here everyone drive to New
York if you want to have you noticed how
I remember we kind of did some stuff
narrative Lee to try to reflect that
saying hey you know we want to speed up
the player to get them to do this but
whenever you get a chance so of you have
you kind of dell no i mean i think it's
only four hours in but a deal that that
the game allows you to play the way you
want to play but also let you know that
there is a story that's happening yes
yeah it doesn't seem to work out pretty
well i mean you have that guy Troy who
kind of chimes in and he's like hey you
know we've got some stuff for you but at
the same time like I don't feel pressure
cool you know like I like Danny said
yesterday you just took a trip to New
York just for the hell of it mm-hmm and
you can do these things and you'll
randomly get phone calls from different
people saying hey you
where you at i'm looking for like I know
that they're putting a lot of emphasis
ours below you know a lot of or all of
you be safe games the moment and i'm the
sort of co-op connectivity stuff like
I'm actually really look forward to just
like soloing this as much as possible
just kind of picking operates here there
I make meatballs now did you shoot can
you choose your camry well you can go
you know okay GTA 5 style yeah it seems
like I mean saying even in this you
would do it do it do it like entering
the city you've had two events that you
could just drive they just pop up in
front of you just drive through and boom
it starts also on the way in Zoe like
chimed in and was like hey there's some
people around here maybe she try to meet
up with them so sort of trying to
encourage that connection with the
narrative or connection with those timed
objectives even when you are just drive
in Chicago cuz your buddy on the couch
told you to yeah the one thing I know
this last night which was a little bit
annoying and it seems like maybe an
oversight was like it was just me and my
roommate Josh and like we were friend
you know we're friends he's the only
friend of mine he misses playing a game
andso he's like hey you've got friends
nearby that want to play me and Josh
were already playing looks like right I
know thank you he did you three seconds
later are you playing with these people
right now no I mean there there there
good good see I can say that though like
I don't feel like I shouldn't slam into
people because I totally can just know
this is how it is in here uh there's a
baby in the back seat to fly to the
windshield oh man what if that was like
care you gotta build is it know how
developers do those things where it's
like if you see this all you're actually
playing the pirated version of the game
well yeah just put like baby on board
sticker
oh alright dry off road oh here we go
there we go now do you feel it if its
defenses meanwhile yeah yeah in fact I
do he's SPECT for streets there's like
five or six different specs and like
unlocks you can do as well towards like
getting better versions of those each
one of the FX as well see more rally car
stuff yeah there is one of those eyes
like the raid look at the higher class
look at those layers that were a baby
head went through which that's next gen
people that's better than anyone yes
yeah look at that we in Wisconsin there
is that what all in the end it's mute
was healing look at that shields not
near cheeseheads something I I gotta say
I even though it may not impact the
physics of how you drive I think and
this is me being stupid it's what resin
I think I would kind of prefer that the
damage stay until you can fix yeah but
it looks like a nominal fee to fix sure
would you want to be able to hot fix it
like just press up on the d-pad like I
got a yeah it's a little bit stranger to
just kind of automatically go yeah but
that's you know oh oh it's good guys
it's cool fine all right okay or even
that would be okay like if I got a
bronze for that my knees knees Chevy's
are really doable
you